können sie das nicht mit was denken sie
was youporn ist
sie möchten gucken ob politiker nur
reden können oder ob sie es auch
schaffen mit ihren händen was
konstruktives konkretes herzustellen
heute machen wir musik instrumente aus
müll oder hostel wo sie lernte ich
bastele äußerst ungern was seine
trompete hier ein trompeten mundstück
oder einen kerzenständer für eine sehr
kleine kerze der klassiker zu sagen ja
aber nur einen docht und moleküle ich
würde suchen
bringen sie da an ton raus
ich glaube schon meinen doch dann gab
erfahren können was machen sie dann aber
wenn sie mir helfen wollen jetzt ist so
wunderbar dass mir so gerne helfen
mir ist aufgefallen dass die fdp
politiker aller so übertrieben attraktiv
sind gerade im kontrast zu den anderen
parteien jetzt meinen sie mich dass ich
meine auch wie kann ich meine vor allem
christian dirr ein absoluter
charmebolzen wir sind schon ein besucher
sich ungesund ja so und jetzt können sie
mal versuchen ein tor
das ist super wie ein sitzender des 7
wir basteln eine rassel für den
rhythmischen backup dafür brauchen wir
ein überraschungsei dürfen sie auch
essen sie möchten brauchen nämlich nur
diese innere bo jessen flüssigkeiten
gerne viel mehr echt hätten wie gerne
schokolade - lassen wie die tegel hat
oder was mit hirn aktiviert haben ich
muss eigentlich auch den zuschauern zu
hause erklären
also liebe zuschauer hallo mama so macht
man das man nimmt eine wie nennt man das
eine boje erinnere
dieses ding im überraschungsei dafür
dass man das mittlere 2 lasse mein
kleber hält mich eh nicht andere hält
mich ja das haben sie jetzt noch mal so
habe stelle ich hätte nicht
einschließlich deutschland waren die
grünen doch besser aus die fdp was haben
die das sieht eine gute geschichte
werden die jetzt in meinen blog raffl
prozent verloren 3 3 prozent zugelegt
haben sie das er gemacht als wir oder
sie waren einfach nur presse dieses mal
war sie vorher so grotesk schlecht waren
man kann schon sagen dass die drei
wissen ergebnis der letzten seit
bestehen des landes coaches schlechte
ergebnisse sind aber auch das letzte
ergebnis für das zweite bis zur seite
stehen schleswig holsteins für die fdp
sie sind ja sehr charakter tipp also man
wählt sie auch weil sie sie nicht loben
während sie dann hätten sie kann ja das
nehmen und dann sagen wir irgendwie
anders schon gemacht
herr kubicki sie haben ja schon die
rasse so schnell fertig gemacht werden
wie das denn so gut hingekriegt dank
dieser hilfe sofort antworten wirklich
der wahrheit verpflichtet ist natürlich
auch die perkussion jetzt machen wir
eine trommel
hier ein paar chips zu nun machen wir
diesen kleinen düsen kann man werbung
machen für die fdp deutlich basta hat er
mal werbung gemacht für die fdp die
würde ich ja die werbung nicht mehr
welcher pornostar für heute werbung
machen ich glaube nicht dass unsere
klientel und so zielgruppe überhaupt
erreichen könne mit porno-stars sendung
zu machen aber an sie können wir noch
nicht sagen dass der durchschnittliche
fdp wähler weniger pornos schaut als ein
grünen-wähler oder cdu wählt weiß ich
nicht tun dann ist es wirklich
ausbeutung wenn irgendwelche armen
frauen pornos drehen dieser niemand
schaut dass wenn ich wirklich daneben
bestimmt tut der welt angefallen
das video zu ende des wechsel drüber zur
richtigen deutsche webseite youtube
kennen sie das nicht mit was denken sie
was youporn ist als rein vom namen her
es ist mithin würde ich will youtube für
leute die porno gucken genau sehr gut
glaubt sie haben das jetzt besser
zusammengefasst auf der bühne auf und
vorn
ich glaube sogar dass wir jemanden
umbringen würden und den mann so sessel
müssten dann leider schon jemanden
schweiz
wir denken aber da ist jede falsche sind
dafür sogar verhindern etwas der falsche
veränder preist brutale sachen wir
wollten einen frisuren basteln mit
christian lehnt aber die hat er jetzt
ohne neue fangen sie das gut dass der
neue hard- oder dachten sie sich der
situation genau wie frauen sich
entscheiden welche früher sowie tragen
wollen ich muss mich nicht ganz
entscheidende jahre in hamburg
ja weil ich mal wie gut wenn da nicht so
gut aussieht warum weil sie dann im
kontrast besser aussieht wird man in der
sie denken glaube ich nur frauen
wenn er denke so nicht wenn er denkt
immer sie seien eigentlich schön
allein hier sie sind ja ein sehr
bekannter flirter sie ihre technik
gibt's da was oder ist es einfach im
blut
ich kann es nicht beschreiben man hat es
oder weil ich nicht gucken mir zum
beispiel so ganz tief in die augen als
ich hab das gefühl sie schauen mir
allein dort wo nicht viele leute
hinsehen können
doch die lederkugel tragen ja gar nicht
ist ja schlimmer als million zu wählen
die man sich anguckt verdacht bestimmt
oder wo man an den falschen ort guckt
wenn man so ein riesiges leberfleck hat
auf den schultern schaut auch immer nur
den überblick und was wollten sie
eigentlich mal werden bevor die eu
geworden sind wenn sie mal beruflich
oder wenn eine kleine jungen wollen ich
wollte markiert werden
dann habe ich festgestellt dass ich
mathematische naturwissenschaftliche
fähigkeiten die physik studieren dann
habe ich eine frau kennengelernt
sie klingt ja fast wie eine junge angela
merkel mit dem studio dann wieder nicht
gerechnet ist auf dem gelernten aktion
gegangen
das ist jetzt aber wirklich für die
einzige möglichkeit zwischen bescheuert
aussieht was ihr lieblingssong jetzt zum
beispiel nehmen sie gern hören was soll
ich ihnen vor trommeln einer von 80
millionen vielleicht einer von 80
millionen ja welches ich nicht kenne
das gebiet in einer von jeden millionen
das ist die schweizer version von dem
song aber dies so ein bisschen krasser
aus wusste sie noch mal drei kleine
komische 3 wobei wir brauchen hier wo
lange nicht gesehen
[Applaus]
was haben sie damals noch etwas gab es
doch queen
beach boys blätter berlin
der drummer von let's swing ist die
anderen eigenen erbrochenen erstickt
wirklich wann kommt ihnen das kotzen im
bundestag
wer gar nicht wahrscheinlich warum nicht
weil ich sie hatten die amelia hart im
nehmen echten aber würden sie zum
beispiel auch für um die koalition
vorzubereiten mit angela merkel flirten
nach dem wahl sind sie so hart im nehmen
er will sich darauf einlassen würde ich
habe schon claudia roth geflossen so die
klage was haben sie da gesagt haben wir
einfach zu jagen oder ersten mal am
steges 172 gesehen was die
jungdemokraten lieber crusoe alten
fischer natürlich erinnert ja mensch zu
jeder zeit gab es ja so bands wie the
who die haben im anschluss alles kaputt
gemacht für dich jetzt auch gerne mit
ihnen tun
sind sie bereit ich bin mir immer bereit
das ist die zerstörung der chips dose in
der eigenen unmündigkeit wolfgang
kubicki ist eine der folgen
[Musik]